we are live in Los Angeles California
and in Southern California just this
past weekend in Fontana of the man who
finished third in the race and he is the
number one Monster Energy Ford car
driver Kurt Busch good to see you sir
how are you brother doing good good to
talking yeah you got it so how is the
race scene in Southern California grown
since you've been around it
Kurt the race scenes intense because
here in SoCal you have drag racing fans
right NASCAR fans IndyCar races Long
Beach and then the drifting that's going
on that's that's caught a lot of
people's attention but Motorsports cars
people everybody loves their cars here
in SoCal and so it's a good Riis weekend
for us to really showcase our sponsors
and to be out there running up front
right I'll be out there running up front
no doubt about it and how has Howard
this is your 20th full season I know
right it's 20 years it's gone by so fast
how was it changed is there anything
that's changed I mean the the biggest
thing technology with the cars and the
way that the engineering staff and the
crew chiefs approached the car set up
the analytics as far as when to pit when
to stay out but yet at the same time
drafting still the same as far as the
enemy of the fact the science is still
the same yeah as far as just tucking in
behind the other car and making the
right moves and as a driver my job is
still to get the best grip out of those
four tires and to make the right moves
at the end of the race how do you do
that I mean it's a funny I mean it's to
feel just like a golf swing and
something like that yes I mean like
exactly like a golfer Thursday is
different than a Sunday and the greats
win on Sunday when the greens are the
hardest right in racing the track is
always rubbered in at the end it's real
slick and that's what you have to have
your setup for that's what you have to
have a feel for to know where to get the
speed Kurt Busch here on the Rich Eisen
show so how has your life changed in the
last 20 years Kurt I feel like I've
settled down finally I've met a nice
girl right right I mean boys are always
later slower in life to figure it out
right right
man I've been blessed and privileged
to have had the chance to make it in
NASCAR I mean I'm a desert kid from
Vegas right and would watch it on TV and
awe and then go I went to my first race
and I was in awe I just went to my 20th
Daytona 500 and I still get that that
kid feel that that butterfly feel of the
energy before the race and yeah I put my
helmet on I go out there and perform and
I would say in 20 years I make smarter
decisions on the track now versus those
gut instincts of just being youthful and
just going off talent right early in my
career but I love it I have great
sponsors great team to race for and
that's the key thing as I signed an
extension with Chip Ganassi Racing last
summer
mm-hmm because I'm in my 19th year then
Annis but I still have a shot to win so
I got shot a championship and that's
that's important to me Kurt Busch here
on the rich has a show what was your
perspective from Ryan Newman's crash did
you see it go down were you where were
you I was actually driving home I had
wrecked out 10 laps before that so you
were driving home I was literally
listening to the radio so you wreck out
10 laps before and you're just like I'm
out of here you've done no I don't stick
around okay no it's it's Daytona man
that place chews you up spit you out and
man you you devastated that you didn't
win right and of course to wreck out
with less than ten laps to go when it
wasn't our fault those are the tough
dejected moments and so yeah I'm
literally driving out heading home and
mm-hmm
I hear it on the radio and like you know
I didn't know the severity of it until I
got home watched it on video and then my
phones blowing up how's Ryan doing how's
Ryan doing because he was taken away
unconscious in an ambulance those sort
of those moments that are not good last
time that had happened in our sport was
Dale Earnhardt senior passed away and
the safety in our sport is incredible
and the impacts that Ryan Newman went
through are tough for anybody no matter
who you are right and for him to survive
that's incredible number two to walk a
white oh yeah I was insane I didn't
expect him to walk now I was litter
texting Tony Stewart who I used to race
for who's a good friend with Ryan Newman
like hey let's get on a plane let's go
see Newman and literally as we're
starting to communicate a trip to go see
him we're watching him walk out it's
amazing
what those babies right you're safe with
his two girls yes - girl's family and
you know like holy cow and so that's our
cars that's the safer barriers that's
our safety equipment does that and that
that improvement came after Dale senior
it did over the last 20 years and that
was that big spike right the Hans device
and and and obviously other members of
this place a Salesman was like hey you
might want to try this on this is 20
years ago mm-hmm I'm like oh the concept
makes sense I've got this device goes
over your shoulders keep your your
helmet attached to this device where
your neck can't extend too far forward I
said sure I'll buy one that's how things
were then now it's we have all of these
safety diagrams we have all these videos
we have all these high def cameras that
can slow-mo a wreck down to watch what
moves in the seat to see what a driver
goes through we have steering wheels
that collapse at the right rate to
create an airbag type of effect there's
so much that we've improved on and
that's exactly what we saw with Newman
walking away so your first thought was
probably my first thought right that he
wasn't walking away from that crash when
you saw it yeah when he probably saw it
on YouTube or video or whatever from
here and everybody thinks the worst yes
but at the same time we haven't had that
happen in 20 years
wait a minute are we gonna have to go
backwards we should be further ahead and
I'm so glad that he walked away yeah
Kurt Busch here in the Rich Eisen show
does your I don't mean I'll ask you a
personal question
does your wife pull you aside after that
and say well you know let's talk about
the future or does anything like that
happen and your I always give her a big
hug and a kiss before and I give her the
assurance and I always say this in this
phrase this quote I'll be right back
sweetie I'll be home for dinner I make
decisions
on the track that I think are on the
safer side yes I'm pushing hard to win
hmm I have the safety in my car the
track and the sport I trust what I'm
doing
I trust others on the track the the
danger aspects always going to be there
it's it's what Auto Racing is that's the
intrigue and the thrill of why people
tune in for me I've never gone across
that threshold and said all right this
is too much I'm gonna keep pushing until
I know my day is done driving and I want
to give my best in my competitive side
to go hard to the end
Kurt Busch here on the Rich Eisen show
all right you and your wife Ashley have
launched a high-end fashion bathing suit
line that a true story that's Ashley's
on top of that game yes so monarch
monarch rain I mean I'm an investor yes
oh so there's no you're not you're not
wearing any of the swimwear there's no I
mean but you could you could go bathing
suit with jeans it's it's like a new
thing what yeah like a one-piece and
jeans that's I that's key man like a
one-piece like like a bathing suit like
I'm in the 20s or something like think
about it yeah for men no okay
nice patterns design okay some mesh
suits with some embroidery right
that's some nice high cut low cut stuff
okay monarch rain Monica very good and
then tell me about the KB 100-plus
ticket giveaway that's going on right
now
that's my initiative yes I'm very proud
to give back to our military I've been
inspired by them on my trips to Walter
Reed and Bethesda Medical Center and to
have a hundred tickets to every NASCAR
race that's what I've available through
vet tix org mm-hmm and the program went
well last year I gave away 4,000 tickets
amazing to our NASCAR we had 50,000
requests so this year I'm calling on
other drivers so Dale jr. helped me out
at Daytona
my little brother helped in Vegas Jimmie
Johnson he added another hundred for
California Speedway where he's from
mm-hmm the guy that were just won Alex
Bowman
he's from Arizona I'm he's hooking us up
with another hunt
in Arizona it's amazing so we're gonna
try it more and more military guys to
the track for free it's on us and it's
great I mean cuz obviously we talk about
ultimate sacrifices right and then you
know what you do for a living and what
you know I'm fortunate to do it for
living it's like the toy department in a
way it is and and and so to be able to
give back like that that's awesome yeah
it's a suit up and a dress sound to go
race a car at 200 miles an hour on
Sunday right it comes at a cost
freedom isn't free and I'm privileged to
have this chance to go and do that and
it's just a small way to give back and
it's really neat to see tracks sponsors
and fans can even donate as well to get
more military members to the track and
how do people do that at Vette tix org
right that's one way to go or first tix
org that's how you can do that yeah vet
tix org is the easiest and then through
my website
Kurt Busch comm there's a link and that
helps people donate fantastic what do
you think of jimmie johnson announcing
his retirement do you think about that I
think it's the right timing
he's a seven-time champion he's won the
Daytona 500 multiple times he's done
everything in our sport and we have a
big transition next year with the next
gen car and I think he's looking to go
out as strong as he can on top with the
car that he knows the team at Hendrick
Motorsports and to not jump into that
next chapter right I think from the time
that we've been together he was a rookie
the year after I was we've been through
four different generations of cars
they're tough when you switch over it's
a whole different driving style I don't
know if I've asked you this question
before enough times have you've been
here do you have an NFL team I do
my family is all from Chicago I grew up
in Vegas so I'm a big Bears fan you know
85 Bears that's right when I was a kid
right but now Vegas as a team Vegas is
getting the Raiders it's gonna be off
the hook I think it's gonna be big why
doesn't Tom Brady just sign with the
Raiders right now and have a year long
party right I mean right the ticket
sales will be through the roof it would
be they're gonna be already well have
you seen that Death Star that they've
built yes it's unbeliev cold Monster
Energy they should sponsor it
and what do they say it probably was a
bill that I wouldn't be able to write
yeah I'm gonna stay out of that I know
you might be wrong stick to driving you
might be Ronnie running on on the lowest
octane of gas a little bit got a cut a
corner here on gas gas cost but it's
just amazing it's a poll southern end of
the strip right across from the airport
across McCarran air now the locations
great they just need to get some bridges
in for pedestrians I mean I'm from Vegas
and write the sports feel in that town
is incredible right now with the Golden
Knights there's a new triple-a baseball
stadium on the west end of town right
this car has two races they still call
the area 51's is that what they're gone
oh they switch from the conspiracy alien
name I couldn't figure that one out so
now you're heading to Phoenix now right
are you are you gonna stop by Cubs
spring training yes
were you down there yeah actually the
the team let me dress out a couple years
ago I did some stretching drills with
the team and then stretching drills I
got batting practice with schwöre burr
oh yeah that was ridiculous now walk me
through this because that is a human
fire hydrant yeah oh dude the balls
cranked out right in the sound when you
did and then like when I hit it knows
that typical t-ball I think and it just
cleared the third baseman maybe but
that's pretty cool it was really I'm a
big Cubs fan big Bears fan and the Cubs
have been great I mean Joe Maddon let me
dress out a couple years ago and so now
I just need a buddy up with coach Ross
well now you know
you know Joe is here with the Angels you
might knock on his door too just because
you're not a Joe Maddon still Joe's a
World Series to Chicago so now as part
of the fact that you didn't hit the ball
very well was that nobody was banging on
a trash can to let you know what's
coming yeah fastball coming in okay all
right you know I texted Verlander about
that and he's just laughing he's
laughing about it what do you mean he's
laughs he's just I gotta just I'm
pleading the fifth all right he's just
laughing about the whole thing
it's your time with Verlander yes it's
not good it's not bad it's just here's
the thing no I mean we've we've talked
about it here Kurt Busch on the Rich
Eisen show what's he supposed to do he's
being caught he he he didn't
No until midnight struck back in that
August of 2017 yeah he was even gonna be
there like he was hearing he was being
trying the Tigers didn't know if he was
going literally got a call at midnight
Astros need him in the worst way and I'm
wondering you know when he gets there
does somebody say to him this is what
we're doing or does he just like sit
there in the dugout and go what's that
noise you know like and it dawns on him
what he's what's he supposed to do I
don't know what you do from that side of
it right because he's got to do the
things as a pitcher with his signs and
to make sure that he's staying ahead of
his hitters so I don't know how much
collaboration goes back and forth
between offense and defense in baseball
right I mean and so and and by the way
look I'm a big Verlander guy and I'm a
die-hard Yankee fan they couldn't hit
him I mean they could not hit him so
even even if there were some sort of
stuff going on he still was pitching
with a one-nothing lead in the ALCS game
and I think very highly of him but
what's he supposed to do now he brought
his best stuff and did his job right as
a pitcher so what's going on on the
other side of the bat I don't know
what's the craziest thing you've seen in
your sport that might be something as
far as like technology technology as a
strategy what have you seen him there
was an era we went through with yellow
flags that were thrown went weird
awkward times what do you mean as far as
may not know the caution flag there
would be debris out on the racetrack or
something and was there really what's
going on why was the yellow so we went
through an error with that but now we
have more of stage breaks so that we
have a guaranteed yellow at a certain
time okay so that took away the
questioning well what were you
questioning that somebody there was
debris out on a track or was there not
debris on the track but so that's not an
officiating call because the track has
to be in a safe race a bowl condition I
see yes and so somebody might have been
tossing something I'm a yellow flag came
out and there's no and there's no red
challenged flag for a yellow flag right
no we just have three from inside the
car and we go what the
yeah that's what it is the button yeah
the button it doesn't do much though
yeah hey Kurt man I love when you stop
by and I appreciate it so again vet
ticks org or Kurt Busch comm writes
right you have to go and be part of the
ticket giveaway program that benefits so
many of our active duty service members
and of course veterans like you've seen
in Walter Reed and people who you know
could use a nice day at the racetrack
that's it yes appreciate having me on to
help me with that because it helps our
military reintegrate after they've been
through a challenging time to know that
there's tickets out there to go to a
NASCAR race going hangout of a family
weekend you got it at Kurt Busch on
Twitter and and send my best ear to your
wife with this you go that's Kurt Busch
right here on the Rich Eisen show 844
204 rich is the number 2